i've been starting businesses since i
was 10 years old and i've always wanted
to be an entrepreneur and so
i think the failures is really what
led me to being able to start this
company and have the success that we've
had
[Music]
my name is john walsh i'm the founder
and ceo of indera and we build electric
vehicles we at our core focus on
innovating technologies to make electric
vehicles cheaper better than gas
vehicles
since i was young right since i was six
years old i was always concerned about
the environment and i also was really
passionate about business i watched the
movie the inconvenient truth in
grade school and it freaked me out you
know just seeing how you know many
carbon emissions were emitting and
you know potentially creating unlivable
planet and so
you know trying to come up with a way
an economically viable approach to
a clean energy
was really what i found was necessary
[Music]
i started my first cleantech company
when i was 18 in high school and then i
started a water company that also had
some you know environmental and
renewable energy kind of spin to it
and i really realized that you know if
you want to create a scalable company
and if you want to have true impact you
have to make it cheaper
and cleaner and dare's mission is to end
the era of fossil fuels finding a way to
do it where you're going to have mass
adoption has been our core focus and so
making it cheaper making it better
making it easier that's what we're here
to do
i'm just getting started
and you know it's been three really
amazing years of growth and want to have
thousands of electric vehicles on the
road thousands of employees because that
is truly how we're going to make an
impact on our planet and reducing carbon
emissions and making a greener world for
everybody so
you know we're going to be a
multi-billion dollar company and we're
gonna save the planet while doing it
[Music]